Aleksey cursory Makaha from the first of
all i would like to thank the organizers
- for putting together this wonderful
workshop and for inviting me anything is
everybody for coming to my talk so today
I will talk about key means and
comedians under dimension reduction and
my talk is based on the joint work with
Constantine McCurry chillin vilya
resents team and let me start with
defining the problems we are going to
talk about today so we study are the
ingredient key means and key medians in
these problems we are given a data set
of points X so every point in X is a
point in a high dimensional space RM we
want to partition X into K clusters C 1
etc CK so as to minimize the fall of an
objective functions so for key median
the objective is to minimize the sum
over all data points you the distance
between you and the center of the
cluster C I that contains you and forkie
means the objective is very similar
except that we square the distances
these two problems are widely used in
practice in particular in machine
learning in big data and arguably these
are among the most used clustering
problems clustering objectives see eyes
are small she eyes are arbitrary points
in the Euclidean space so they are not
in the dataset
there's your big Caesar in data point so
a little confusing as you said we see in
each PC right that's at a a type for
each for each side not in each C I for
each said that this is a type a sir
yeah any other questions about the
problems so these are the problems we
are going to study now let's switch
gears for a moment and talk about
dimension reductions so a dimension
reduction is a random map from a high
dimensional space are M into much
smaller
D dimensional space
Rd that approximately preserves
distances with high probability more
precisely we consider a map that
preserves the distance between U and V
up to a factor of 1 plus Epsilon we have
probability at least 1 minus Delta for
every u and V and here abyssal and Delta
are the parameters dimension reductions
we were introduced and studied by
Johnson in Lyndon straws in 1984 and we
showed that there exists a family of
random dimension reductions with
dimension equal to log 1 over Delta over
1 over epsilon squared and that was
relatively recently shown by Larson and
Nelson this dependence of G on Delta and
epsilon is actually optimal dimension
reductions are widely used in computer
science in particular for data
compression so if you have a data set in
a high dimensional space we can compress
it by applying a dimension reduction in
particular if you have a data set on
endpoints and the dimension is
logarithmic and man
we can by applying a dimension reduction
we can preserve the all of the pairwise
distances with high probability and
there is a wide body of literature on
dimension reductions and these are just
some peepers on the toy deck for the
purpose of this talk let's assume that
our dimension reduction is based on a
random orthogonal projection onto a
d-dimensional space or a random good
garrisoned projections and now let's get
back to to our problems key means and
key medians and so we have a data set in
a high dimensional space and it's
natural to do the following
instead of clustering this data set in a
high dimensional space let's first
project it into a small D dimensional
play space cluster it in the D
dimensional space and yet we desired
clustering which will correspond to
clustering in the high dimensional space
so this approach was proposed and
started by both cheetahs at all of
course in order for this approach to be
me and full we want each to preserve the
cost of the classroom so you want the
cost of the clustering in very high
dimensional space to be approximately
equal to the cost of the class drink in
the smaller dimensional space and I did
I mean the bare minimum we want the cost
of the optional clustering to be
approximately the same but ideally we
want the cost of every classroom to be
the same and then we are guaranteed that
when we project our dataset into D
dimensional space find a good clustering
in this space it will correspond to a
good clustering in the original space so
let's hear for which dimensions D we can
get this
so first of all give a dimension is
logarithmic in M it's easy to see that
the cost of every plastering is
preserved up to a factor of 1 plus
epsilon with high probability and as a
warm-up we will see how to prove that
now boo tedious at all who initiated
this line of research showed that it is
sufficient to have dimension ki over
epsilon squared and then the cost of the
class strings are preserved up to a
factor of 2 plus epsilon and note that
this bound on the dimension does not
depend on them
so if ki epsilon and Delta fixed and n
goes to infinity then steel this
dimension remains a constant so this is
very important cone at all later
improved the result of booties both boot
sealers at all and showed that when the
dimension is linear and key the
distortion is actually 1 plus Epsilon
infer that they show that when the
dimension is logarithmic and ki the
distortion is at most 9 plus epsilon in
order to show that when the dimension is
logarithmic in key V distortion is 1
plus Epsilon and these bound on the
dimension is essentially tight because
it's easy to see that the dimension mark
be at least low key over epsilon squared
so in our formula the you some extra
them dependence on absent so we have
this absent and we don't know whether
this epsilon is necessary or not so
after this absent our bound is optional
let me mention that in many applications
like he is much much smaller than n so
see we want to classify some items then
n is the number of items
and key is a number of categories so it
need to see logarithmic in an and then
our bound is law blog and while the
trivial bomb gives log n yeah for all
pass drinks now let's talk about key
medians so for key medians they were no
prior resolve even in contrast to he
means the log and bound is not is not
obvious for key medians it follows
however from the huge balance theorem
and why they asked the question what
happens with comedians here at Simon's
at a tutorial talk in in August we
showed that when did I mention is low
key of a rap song over absence well then
the cost of every clustering is
preserved up to a factor of 1 plus
Epsilon and again this bound is
essentially optimal after this epsilon
you have any questions about the results
where's the theorem
where is what does it say our aetherium
oq power here so I mean okay it says
that if you have a c1 Lipschitz map from
a subset of allegiance piece to region
space we can extend it without
increasing the Lipschitz constant later
on I will merely briefly talk about it
but most likely I do not have to T I do
not have enough time to take to tell
anything kind of meaningful about it
any other questions okay so this is an
overview of my talk so we will focus
mostly on key means today and first we
will discuss some of the challenges with
the proof then as a warm-up we will see
that when the dimension is a logarithmic
eman the cost of all of the class
strings are approximately preserved
under dimension reduction then we will
discuss a very important special keys
and I can't define it formally now but
loosely speaking in this special keys
all the distorted distances are
uniformly distributed inside clusters so
you don't have clusters to where there
are a lot of distorted distances but I
will of course formally define it later
on and then we will see how to remove a
small number of the outliers in our data
set so that the Romanian points satisfy
this condition from the special keys and
by doing so you'll see that the cost of
all points other than outliers is
preserved in some sense and finally
because here what to do with the
outliers in the very end of the talk we
will spend a couple of minutes
discussing the key medians
problem so this is our plan for today
let me now formulas to eat our result so
we are given our data set X it's a
subset of our M and we have a random
dimension reduction Phi from RM to R D
we assume that these at least this
quantity and here s 1 is at the desired
distortion and Delta is the feeler
probability and we show that this
probability at least 1 minus Delta the
cost of every cluster in C is
approximately preserved after a factor
of 1 plus Epsilon
any questions okay now that's yeah so
this probability this probability no
matter what clusters UT you get this so
this probability for all plots or
simultaneously this happens and this is
importantly we use this in practice
because otherwise maybe you know we will
find some you know for each specific
dimension reduction you'll find that bad
clustering and then you know that's bad
yeah any partition even if it's huge not
a suboptimal center point centers don't
have to be I mean we prove that for all
clusters right right but they agree that
in practice mean we don't care about all
clusters but still you prove that for
all you know
those curses are the optimal ones for
payments right so to get all clusters
about being the process to occur to
Center than the motes they're not part
of the optimization essence all right
but but also if you have a board on a
partition in the projection it doesn't
really respond over on the projection in
the original space and why you're so so
we should be really careful with that
but basically I agree so let's see now
what the challenges are and assume for a
moment that we want to approve a week
result you only want to prove that the
cost of the optimal classroom does not
decrease much and it's not hard to prove
that he batik the optimal clustering
keep XI star then the cost of C star is
approximately equal to the cost of the C
star projected so this is actually
pretty easy to show now what is
challenging is to prove that there is no
other cluster in C prime which is much
better under projection so maybe there
is a suboptimal class 3 C Prime but once
we project C prime into a low
dimensional piece the cost of C prime
drastically decreases or decreases by a
factor of more than one perception and
now it's considerably better than the
optimal clustering again for every
specific C prime it's not hard to prove
but we have exponentially many different
class drinks and the probability that
each of them violates this property is
loosely speaking Delta which does not
depend on them and me.we amazing that
it's it's some constant ok so this is a
challenge the challenges that we have
exponentially many different class
drinks and each of them is a projection
attention you might be better than the
optimal clustering
okay now let's assume that G is
logarithmic in an and CY in this case
the claim is easy and here it's very
useful for us that we can write the
objective function in terms of pairwise
distances between points so we use this
formula for the cost of clustering see
this is a pretty well-known formula we
just take the sum of all pairwise
distances inside of each cluster and be
normalized appropriately now if the
dimension is logarithmic in man
then all pairwise distances between the
points in acts are approximately
preserved up to 1 plus Epsilon
there are for all these charms are
approximately preserved and we get that
the cost of every class drink is
approximately preserved now this
approach does not work when the
dimension is algorithmic in key because
each term is is significantly distorted
with a constant probability it was a
small constant probability Delta so we
will have many charms that are distorted
and we need somehow to take care of
these kind of distorted terms now let me
introduce some notation yeah so the cost
is this sum within cluster distances is
that right so one way to define it it's
the distance between the points and the
center squares
squared but another way is to use this
formula this is the distances in high
dimensional space are larger than the
ones
dimensional space right when you project
you all kind of renormalized radiation
that all this you know in expectation
the distance doesn't change any other
questions like if you put all the points
just on one Center which would be a very
bad thing to do with this all be within
cluster distances are all zero so would
that be a very low cost or if you what
what if you give it a very trivial what
what if the the embedding or the
projection it's all the points just
together in one point yeah that will be
bad with that show up badly in this cost
the court will go down significantly
yeah I mean if you project everything
into one point it has a cost from some
some positive number will go down to
zero so then by your the way that you're
measuring the cost wouldn't that be a
good Keynes then oh right but we don't
want to change we don't want you know
it's also bad for us in the original
instance the cost of the clustering is
high but once we projected the cost is
is low then you know we don't preserve
the objective function so that's that's
not good for us
absolutely correct
today so you just a list of costs are
just a
any other questions okay let me
introduce some notation so for every
specific projection Phi let cow this
trust me savanna Tracey key to be the
most distorted classroom so kind of
rebirth classroom for this specific
projection for this dimension reduction
then this e is a random plastering
because because Phi is random and you
mention that this year is simply a
function of the random projection and we
want to prove that the cost of this mole
distorter class during C is
approximately preserved under dimension
reduction with high probability and also
let's say that the distance between U
and V is 1 plus epsilon preserved if you
have these approximate equality and if
this approximate equality does not hold
we see that the distance is distorted
also we will think that the parameter
Delta is when animals are small in 1
over key and that's on so it
sufficiently small but still when key
and depths on I fixed this is a constant
so in particular Delta of course does
not depend on them but if you'll be we
don't need that it's feature small okay
since we are particularly interested in
the charms and in you know in the in the
expression for the cost that are not
preserved let's introduce the distortion
graph in the distortion graph we can so
the distortion graph is the graph on the
set of data points and two points U and
V are connected with an edge if the
distance between them is distorted so
this is a random graph so it depends on
the dimension reduction on the random
dimension reduction now
good news is that every age is present
in this graph this probability at most
Delta this is guaranteed by our property
that our map is a dimension reduction
the bad news is a doubt is not very
small in particularly doesn't depend on
n so in some sense a constant fraction
of all the ages are present also the bad
news is that ages are not independent of
this graph and the clustering here
depends on the dimensional reduction in
particular on the set of the distorted
ages in particular our graph may have
high degree vertices so it may happen
that many distances from a specific
point are distorted it may also happen
that we have a small cluster and all or
moved or the distances inside of this
cluster I just ordered so in a sense
this is pretty bad news for us because
then the cost of this classroom is not
preserved right so it mean even though
we are going to prove that the cost of
the clustering is approximately
preserved it's not true that the cost of
every cluster is approximately preserved
at least when you talk about a
multiplicative Distortion ok now let's
let's analyze the problem using the
distortion graph so as we know the cost
of every cluster CI is given by this
formula now if u and V are not connected
with an edge so if the distance between
u and V is approximately preserved then
this storm is distorted up to 1 plus
epsilon so basically there is no
difference I mean the amount of this
term contributes to the original problem
and to the projected problem is the same
we don't have any issues with this chart
and what we need to do we need
take care of the terms for the ages for
the distorted distances and what you are
going to prove that eBay add up all
these terms over ages in the original
instance and in the projected instance
then we differ by small some apps on
prime times the cost of the clustering
see and that's on prime here you'll dip
it's a small medium of weather apps on
over key ok what is important that we
get this in this approximate equality up
to some additive error so we cannot have
a multiplicative error here because I'm
in particularly it may happen that one
of these sums is very close to zero and
the other is not okay so this is our
plan and first let's consider a special
but very important case where all the
artists have low degrees in their
clusters so let's assume that every
vertex in our graph have is connected to
few your tissues in its cluster more
precisely what we require the TV tick
every vertex you in a cluster see I then
I just connected to add more some 1
minus theta fraction of all the vertices
in the same cluster okay note that this
bound on the degree depends on the
cluster see we have a large cluster the
bound is larger if you have a small
cluster than the bound on the degree is
smaller because we consider only its
neighbors in the cluster and we and and
the number of neighbors should be at
most I'll say it should be not 1 minus
heat it should be a theta fraction so it
should be feeling a theta fraction of
all vertices in the class ok so let's
assume that this happens
and now you are going to bound all turns
u minus V squared again we don't have
any issue with non ages so for every
known age the charm is approximately
preserved we are going to show that the
contribution of chance for ages is small
and there are four we can essentially
ignore it so let's consider an age give
ear size that U and V belong to CI and
let's take an arbitrary point W inside
then by the trend on equality we have
list and by squaring we get this in
equality now let's choose W uniformly at
random
inside cluster CI ok and then e when we
do this each charm will be selected at
most 2.2 to Delta x in expectation so
every term will be selected Pizzarelli
and from that we get that the sum of U
minus V squared over all ages is at most
8 a delta 8 delta x this sum the sum
over all u and v in the cluster okay and
note that this expression is the cost of
the cluster and a doubt is very small so
what we see is that the contribution of
these terms corresponding to the
distorted ages is very small compared to
the total cost of the cluster and
essentially we can ignore it
okay it should be it should be theta
right you should be Sita so it should be
CT here so so here we use that every
vertex is connected to me that most
theta neighbors inside its class or so
we're all sort of Fe diffraction of the
edges and here it's important that this
bound on the degrees uniform any
questions
ticking what we just showed that the
cost of the cluster is approximately
equal to the sum over all known ages we
know that the value of this sum is
approximately preserved under dimension
reduction so we have this approximate
equality and the gear again for using
the same argument we know that this sum
is approximately equal to this son so we
see that if this special property is
satisfied then the cost of the
clustering is approximately preserved
but in general of course we cannot
assume that this property a special
property holds in particular because our
clustering depend on the distortion
graph and let's let's try the following
let's try to remove a small set of the
outliers from our instance so that they
remain in the instance satisfied
satisfies the desired property so this
is what you want to do be first or get
the random dimension reduction it
defines the distortion graph we also get
a clustering which depends on the
dimension reduction in this classroom we
may be a high degree of your tissues
like this vertex this vertex we may have
even very dense clusters or potentially
a classroom may be a clique we remove a
small number of the outliers so here
they represented as black
purchases and in the obtained instance
all degrees all the artists have small
degrees so we use the previous argument
formally we want to remove the outliers
and up obtain a subset X prime which we
call called the non distorted core so
that the fallen into prodigious Hall
first of all ages are sparse in the
obtained clusters so basically the
special property that we talked about
holds for the Romanian clusters and the
second property is that outliers are
rare so the probability that you is an
outlier is at most thither okay and let
me let me stress that the set of the
outliers does depend on the random
dimension reduction so it's a random set
let's see how you find these these
outliers and let's first assume that all
clusters are large so all clusters of
size and our key approximately and let's
fit it be loosely speaking Delta ^ want
water let's remove all the or tissues of
high degree from our graph so more
precisely or vertices of degree Utley at
least fit and over key and then the
meaning vertices have degree less than
theta n over K so since the size of
every plaster is approximately and our
key this means that every vertex is
connected to at most a feet a fraction
of the original cluster now simply
because every age is distorted with
probability so the every distance is
distorted this probability Delta the
expected degree of every vertex is at
most Delta n and applying markers in the
quality we get that it's highly unlikely
that if your text has degree greater
than this and so we remove every Georgia
to be is a small probability probability
lesson Seaton and finally since we
remove every vertex with a very small
probability it's likely that we will
remove a very small fraction of the
purchases and because of that it's
unlikely that any cluster will
significantly shrink and because of that
not only the degree of every vertex is
at most seated times the size of the
cluster of times the original size of
the cluster it's also at most feet or
maybe you know two theta times the size
of the new cluster after we remove the
outliers so in this case so if all the
clusters a large the analysis is simple
but in general this is not given some
clusters can be small and then this
analysis doesn't go through in
particularly it's not sufficient to
remove vertices of degree at least theta
n over K because a cluster can be much
smaller than an hour K and also when we
remove outliers it may happen that we
will remove most of your teachers from
the cluster and then again this argument
will not go through and yeah and loosely
speaking our idea is as follows we want
to assign weight to the points so that
with respect to these bits every cluster
is hidden and then we will essentially
reduce the analysis to the previous keys
more formally we prove the fall event
comunitaria lama
so we prove the Divis a measure mu on x
and the random set of
our pliers are so that after we remove
these outliers from our the measure of
every point is greater than one over the
size of the new cluster this means that
all points are sort of heavy we also
have this condition that says that the
total weight of all points is relatively
small so it's bounded by a polynomial
and key in theater and that we remove
every point be small probability so I
don't want to talk about this in any
detail so this is Bridget technical
lemma and Bridget technical analysis but
basically using of is llama we can
reduce the general keys to the keys
where all clusters are of approximately
the same size so using these techniques
we can take here of all points other
than outliers
so now let's see what we do with the
outliers so suppose that we have a
cluster and we have these black points
that are outliers we need to analyze the
contribution of ages between outliers
and edges between outliers and non
outliers the analysis is a bit different
but let's look what happens with these
ages so let's assume that you is an
outlier and V is not and let's consider
a fixed optimal clustering of X so this
classroom see one star it's a twisty key
star and let's he start this point C
star be the optimal Center for you in
this classroom so if you write the
triangle inequality for u minus V so u
minus V is equal to V minus C star to
these distance up to this storm the
distance between U and C star so you
have this approximate equality we have
the same approximate equality in the
projection
now when we define the non distorted
clock core we may actually assume that
all distances from the points and the
core to optimal centers are
approximately preserved and we can do
that because there are only key optimal
centers so with a reasonable probability
the distance from every point to all
these key centers is preserved and if we
add if we remove extra outliers those
points for which the distance to one of
the optimal centers is not preserved we
will essentially get the same analysis
so we have this approximate equality and
now we want to show that the total
contribution of these terms and these
terms is small so let's let's take care
of these terms his star minus u so what
we do we add these terms up over all
points you that are outliers and now we
know that every point is an outlier with
a small probability so simply by the
linearity of expectation we have this
bound its Sheeta the probability that U
is an outlier times this expression and
this expression is the optimal cost so
we get that the total contribution of
all these terms is at most theta times
opt now the analysis of the total
contribution of these terms is more
involved because the event that U is an
outlier depends on Phi so we don't have
independence here but we still show that
the contribution of these terms is small
and also there is another technical
issue here that we have this triangle
and like voltages for Euclidean
distances and then the objective we have
squared Euclidean distances so that at
some work but it's possible to take care
of that and this basically concludes the
proof
Linnea finally say if you are at about
key medians so for key medians the
problem is more difficult because we
don't have a simple formula that
expresses the cost in terms of pairwise
distances so we have to consider the
optimal centers and that complicates
things significantly so to solve this
problem we prove a robust version of the
cute blonde theorem that I mentioned and
using the techniques I just described
and the Chris Brown theorem we are able
to get our result for key medians in in
summary let me tell you what we did so
we proved that the cost of every class
drink is preserved when the dimension is
logarithmic in key our result applies to
key means key medians and more generally
to any sort of Euclidean key clustering
with the LP objective and I'll be happy
to tell you more about this offline and
in particular our results for he means
answers and open problem by cohen at all
thank you
[Applause]
yeah I'm just thinking about
approximation algorithms for finding
k-means clustering so I don't really
know what's the state of the art if
there's something known that's
polynomial in all MDK and we can't we
cannot solve the reason approximation
algorithm but maybe we cannot solve the
problem in polynomial time in M and K
and 1 over Epsilon
but many algorithms ma you know if you
have an algorithm even an approximation
algorithm and we project our data set in
a low dimensional space then the
algorithm the algorithm will be are
faster so this is this is probably one
of the mean applications and you know we
don't need much more much less memory so
potentially yeah potentially the
algorithm may also give a better
approximation guarantee but I don't know
if it's necessarily the keys
all right listen can you again so we're
coming back at you